j'adore alors on a on a un chauffeur à
la table qu'on est enceinte de minutes
cgc jean pascal
vous êtes soffer j'ai commencé ma et
saufs ils étaient sauveteurs en mer oui
bah attendait sauver des vies bien sûr
mais je dois alerte à malibu non moi
c'était plus arrête le mali bus de l'été
mais c'était consommer avec modération
opération qu'il faut pour degrés avant
d'être pompier j'ai sauvé la vie à trois
enfants mais j'ai été décoré de le
courage et dévouement qui vous a repéré
c'était pour la star composait affairés
sur la plage sur la plage pendant
j'étais pompier ou sur ma dernière année
ah ouais ouais bon c'est fait et ce que
j'aurais pété à préciser les choses
d'abord ils ont écarté toutes les
conneries et de dire vraiment que j'ai
payé puis à prévoir parce que pas
parenthèse abbaoui dans les relations tu
nous fais de bien faire mais on est on a
tenu la baraque dans le casting il se
foutait éperdument de savoir si vous
aimez chanter ou par les lecteurs
évidemment j'étais à bout de bois façon
même après à tubes de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3nous en plein dans 984 venir comme
cervelle de la musique
bravo mesdames si vous avez un problème
on a sauveteurs est acceptable qui
pourra n'est pas ce cours qui sera le
meilleur bilal ce soir on a trois
candidats se sont habillées maquillées
coiffées comme toi tour à tour et vont
venir faire une petite prestation on
démarre avec bilal morini bosc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
toutes mes excuses à laure
à
[Applaudissements]
quand je rêve je suis en droit quand je
rêve je suis un point
[Musique]
et enfin on termine avec l'agitateur
jean bilal
que c'est
un jour je suis pas
[Musique]
bon jeu
je suis en vie
[Musique]
ou même
bonjour
et jean pascal pas mal on voit qu'il a
fait la star ac
alors qu'harry on se souvient de la
sortie tout d'abord autant d'albums
cultes est venu me voir d'ailleurs or
noir
tu disais que tu allais pas faire du rap
toute ta vie on est toujours le cas ou
pas bien sûr que tu vas faire tu veux
faire autre chose complètement tu veux
faire un autre style de musique
non je veux continuer mais je pense que
j'ai trop de choses à jaro tout dans la
vie
ouais une confiserie aussi d'assurer une
question envie de faire attention débute
en chocolat allez on n'a pas donné il va
vendre des dragibus mais qu'est ce que
tu aimes dans la vie c'est qui c'est
quoi tu as envie de faire quoi s'ils
arrêtent le rap star est de chanter on
se mouche pas du tout mes chansons plus
douces un petit duo avec moi peut-être
pas sympa qu'est ce qu'il ya ça me
tirait mec de l'agitateur tous les deux
ont fait nous avions l'air à 2
[Musique]
ouais il alonso c'est bon je sais qu'à
faire ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
question que vous posez des questions
donc je posais des questions sur vous en
faites à nos trois pirates qui sont là
bas au dessus pas de la main il ya une
vague de force secte au dessus de
jean-michel il ya une fiente de mouettes
ont reçu de jean pascal
il y a les restes de la soupe de poisson
de l'équipage alors s'ils répondent mal
rien entendu ils se feront à rose
continue ses pairs du également jean
pascal
combien de films comporte la saga halo
miller avec christophe lambert 3 14,4 et
rennes c'est carlo et oui c'est car
ouais ouais euh ça tombe pas dessus
pascal et attention on joue pour une
question bonus fait si vous répondez
bien tous les trois vous gagnez un week
end ans pas bon vous nettoyez vous
reposer car jean mi attention les
chirurgiens quel a été le premier métier
de christophe lambert christophe tu ne
souffle pas vous avez trente secondes
pour trouver qui ne lit non
c'est possible les gars de casseurs de
servir les chéris écoutez bien potable
qui a la bonne réponse de ce que vous
avez dit en fait
christophe quel était votre premier
métier vendeur de chocolat
alors jean pascal forcément star ac
jean-pascal star ac' jean pascal à gaza
alors vous alors après la question est
ce que ça vous dérange déjà un biopic
sur et le marché alors j'ai eu la chance
de le rencontrer une fois moi ça me met
juste un peu mal à l'aise parce que
j'adore tf1 jamais prendre acte est
fermé et j'ai la sensation qu'on se sert
beaucoup de ça si on dit par exemple je
ne sais pas peut-être que c'est le cas
mais que tf1 on fait ça pour que tout ce
qui va être gagné en argent va être
versée pour la cause pour la recherche
je trouve ça ils l'ont ils ont beaucoup
fait ils ont fait mon concert il ya de
grosses émissions qui ont fait 4 52
qu'ils ont très bien marché avec une
grosse collecte de dons donc ça pour une
fois ça a été fait moi je moi comme je
le ressens rien bien sûr moi je pense
que je le ressens et je vais te sérieux
pour une fois donc si vous le pouvez
filmer ça va être
je ressens un peu trop le côté business
autour malheureusement de la maladie
même quand y avait la star ac
des fois je c'était un peu trop si ça
peut aider la recherche est bien mais
des fois j'ai moi ça me met mal à l'aise
quoi je parle j'ai pas fini
j'ai passé quelque chose alors c'est
quelque chose que moi perso je vais pas
regarder parce que voilà ça me fait mal
au coeur en peluche quelqu'un d'assez un
peu je me cache derrière le nez rouge et
c'est souvent la larme à l'oeil mais
c'est quelque chose qui me mettait mal à
l'aise moi perso j'ai re a dit moi je
suis la polémique un peu obscène ce sont
les mêmes qui en tête de gondole vont
dire que les [ __ ] c'est pas bien
parce qu'anna qui font ça pour leur
propre pub bassin lafleur a fait comme
le di francesca ses légumes en cause
si on a qui disent et qui donne de
l'argent à cette maison qui va sourire
en 2021 qui va accueillir jusqu'à 400
patients par année ça change voilà moi
je trouve que c'est très positif
et c'est très important mais j'ai accru
les villes en asie du nord est alors
jean pascal roux dit ce que vous avez
dit vendredi qu est ce que vous avez dit
vendredi qui a fait qu'à créer polémique
j'ai dit que tf1 allait diffuser quelque
chose qui me mettait mal à l'aise
pourquoi parce que pour moi moi j'ai un
rapport très compliqué avec la mort
c'est pour ça que je veux pas voir le
biopic sur une perle est décédé j'ai du
mal à de la mort d'accord ou super pas
pour ça vous n'avez pas regardé notre
langage les critiques et grégory où
l'association
ou alors montré les images et ce qui
m'embête c'est que quand on fait quelque
chose pour une association je pense que
tf1 peut le faire ou on joue le jeu à
100% parce que ya pas eu que grégory il
ya des centaines malheureusement il ya
plein de gosses qui sont malades pleines
de gens on reverse tout tf1 n'est pas
donc oui faut un coup ils disent ok on
fait quelque chose
sur grégory et en reverse et c'est très
bien folie et c'est bien pour la
recherche et j'espère que c'est ce que
vous ferez vous ferez avec votre s'était
déjà heurté de plein fouet parce qu'il
ya votre album mais je vais finir je
vais pas les dialysés les sûr de finir
sur les droits d'auteur tout vous
ressenti sekkaki de la chanson tout mais
c'était une chanson qui existait déjà
robert c'est tout mais c'est super parce
que le fond du sujet là parce qu a pas
de débat parce que malgré vos vidéos
autour mais tu mettrais des hypocrites
tu entends pas ce que nous savons déjà
peiné et ça a peiné tout les gens qui
soutient grégory qui soutiennent
l'association sûr tu nous a fait
vraiment de la peine est ce pareil j'en
attends je termine juste mon propos pour
moi quoi une autre paire attends je
termine juste mot pour nous tue c'est
parti même que tu le veuilles ou non de
la famille star académie c'est comme ici
à une famille tpm p on crache pas sur
les anciens la secte je me crachent sur
rachid arhab à mes copains tu nous fait
du mal en fait mais ce que nous on
terrain on n'a rien contre toi t'as pas
le droit de dire qu'on est hypocrite à
chaque bras dire qu'on n'a pas le mien
parce que grégory nous a unis dans
quelque chose on se bat pour lui en
donne tout attention évidemment dans un
monde parfait ce serait bien que tf1 qui
redonne tout près s'érigea ils vont
parler au moins de l'assaut alors alors
je vous n'êtes pas se soulagent malaisie
- de fait je le droit d'analyser mois le
client
j'ai vu a le droit d'avoir le deuil et
bien sûr je vais juste finir comme je
vous écoute je vais juste si vous en
faites pas vous mais tout est juste j'ai
regardé le clip mois la manière dont ces
tournées la manière dont ces films et
alors je suis pas une grande acteurs
comme vous le dites certes mais quand
j'aurai quelque chose qui me que je
trouve je trouve pas cette vidéo ce que
je trouve ces voix là c'est ce côté un
peu on se retrouve on pleure si vous
êtes vus depuis laisse moi finir je vais
pas parler en votant mais tu allais le
faire quand vous vous êtes parlé lundi
voir pendant apparemment depuis 14 ans
on pleure en tissu ou il ya tout le
temps vous pleurez pas pourquoi vous
l'avez pas fait avant donc c'est juste
ce côté pour moi si hypocrite est trop
fort pour vous j'espère que les termes
comme langue depuis tu es tout ça ne
semble pas aussi fort que je sais pas
comment j'aurais réagi parce que pour
moi société sur ce coup là c'est une
instance et il a essayé mais il n'y a
pas de débat
moi je parle vous savez ce que c'est
elle la finalité tout ça c'est les dons
mais je suis très heureux et tout quand
tu ne te ra dickey de la lumière
les menteurs les heureux qu'ils aient eu
de la lumière faite sur votre album ça
va pousser les ventes et je n'aime pas
l'initiative de tout ça donc il y aura
des dons pour l'association et c'est ça
le fond de l'histoire alors non